j'embauche un menteur un menteur ou une
monteuse j'ai mis un moteur pour la
lisibilité de la fif pour la messe 120
minutes sur youtube mills aurait pu être
un monteur une menteuse
puisqu'il n'y a absolument pas de
discrimination de sexe je cherche
quelqu'un qui va venir travailler avec
moi au quotidien
je cherche quelqu'un en qui je vais
pouvoir avoir confiance quand même qu'il
va nous apporter des choses s'aggravent
nous permettra d'aller beaucoup plus
loin sur youtube et ailleurs il ya plein
de projets il ya plein de choses à faire
j'ai plein de choses dans les tuyaux
dans mes petits paquets dans mes petits
sacs pleins de choses que j'ai envie de
faire que je fais malheureusement
aujourd'hui par manque de temps je peux
pas tout faire tout seul
l'idée c'est donc de multiplier par deux
les effectifs de la boîte passer de un
mois à 2 on sera donc de non pas le 3
lui il a pour plus tard on sera donc
deux ans aurait donc deux je cherche
donc le ou la candidat candidate idéale
pour mieux rejoindre sa peau ce qui est
basé à paris c'est un poste à temps
plein j'ai donc pris plein de notes sur
ce que je ressens pas cela en fait je
veux faire en recrutement un peu
différent on va donc se faire un
recrutement ici par la vidéo il faut
envoyer toutes vos candidatures à l'iml
jobs
@ monsieur greu point fr l'email et
affiches et là je vous le remet en bas
en dessous dans la description vous m'en
voyez tous vos fichiers vous expliquer
ça j'ai pris des notes dans mon petit
smartphone pour vous dire exactement ce
que je recherche
ce que j'attends de vous et de québec
investit un recrutement alors je veux
voir ce que vous faites ce que vous êtes
capable de faire est ce que vous avez à
me proposer
voir où est ce que vous pouvez m'emmener
ou est-ce que votre créativité ou est-ce
que votre vision ou est-ce que votre
connaissance de la chaîne ou même pas
forcément connaissance de la chaîne vous
pouvez ne pas être abonné vous pourriez
ne pas connaître la chaîne est tombé là
parce que quelqu'un a partagé
l'annonçant disant ok ya ce mec là qui
recrutent va voir ça peut être
intéressant que vous connaissiez ou vous
connaissiez pas la chose que je demande
c'est pas forcément d'être un passionné
de tech mais c'est d'avoir envie d'être
créatif de vouloir repousser les limites
de faire toujours mieux d'être gens plus
loin ça c'est vraiment le plus le
leitmotiv c'est le coeur c'est lille et
c'est ce que je veux alors ce que vous
demandez je voudrais faire une vidéo à
partir des rushes de ma chaîne vous
prenez ce que vous voulez je crois qu'à
800 et quelques vidéos sur ma chaise je
vous laisse choisir je vous autorise à
les télécharger une vidéo uniquement
dans le cadre de ce recrutement là vous
vous puissiez monter des vidéos pour
voir effectivement ce que vous proposez
leur il existe des outils en ligne pour
pouvoir télécharger des vidéos youtube
dimanche devrait pas trop vous le dire
mais je vous autorise à récupérer mes
vidéos pour pouvoir travailler dessus
uniquement dans le cadre du recrutement
alors je n'aurai deux choses deux vidéos
ont parlé de recontre quelle est votre
vision qu est ce que vous pensez vous
pourriez
tu es de cabella mollet fourier ne
passait pas 15 jours dessus il ne
passait pas tous devenus dessus parce
que vous savez je publie une vidéo tous
les jours ça veut dire que en venant
travailler le lundi en finissant le
vendredi soir aidé il faut avoir fait
cette vidéo est plus parce qu'il va y
voir d'autres formes a développé vous
explique asad en quelques temps pour
l'instant le plus important c'est de
voir helmand quel est votre sensibilité
et comment est ce que vous travaillez
sans je manque de me faire une vidéo
vous prenez les rushs que vous voulez
vous faites ce que vous voulez vous me
faites la vidéo vous voulez vous demande
juste de me faire rire il faut que cette
vidéo raconte une histoire sur la tête
je veux pas vous en dire plus pour pas
vous influencer fait vraiment ce que
vous voulez prenez des bouts de vidéos
là un bout de vidéo là un bout de ce
côté-là raconter l'histoire que vous
voulez avec de la vois pas de la voie de
la musique qu'est ce que vous voulez
travailler votre storytelling et montrez
moi ce que vous savez faire comme vous
le verriez fait vraiment ce que vous
voulez je vous laisse le champ libre là
dessus choisissez la musique ce que vous
dites ce que vous voulez faites vraiment
selon vos goûts selon votre perspective
sur votre vision pour se rencontrent ça
c'est le premier point c'est très très
très créatif c'est très globale il n'y a
pas de calais charges particulier en sus
si ce n'est que moi je sais ça vous
captez et à vous de ville et au travers
cette vidéo ça c'est la première vision
la deuxième vidéo elle va être un peu
plus écrite
je voudrais me faire un teaser pour la
chaîne alors se disant ne sera pas
utilisée en aucun cas c'est une fois de
plus pour réussir à voir de quelle
manière vous percevez la chaîne vous
pouvez prendre n'importe quel rush de ma
toute première vidéo où je présente la
chaîne et où j'explique qui je suis ce
que je fais où je vais aller d'ailleurs
d'où un peu catastrophique
c'était le début c'est normal jusqu'à
maintenant vous prenez ce que vous
voulez faire ce que vous voulez c'est un
teaser qui doit raconter
l'idée de la chaîne qui je suis vite ce
que je fais ou est-ce que je vous emmène
et pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut s'abonner
à la chaîne est pas mal la petite vidéo
et regardez il ya pas mal de choses à
venir chercher sur la chaîne
laissez libre cours à votre imagination
et dites vous bien que ce que je
recherche c'est à vous sentirez à
deviner mode fibre artistique derrière
et qu'est ce que vous voyez de camélia
vous travaillez je vous laisse donc
faire ces deux vidéos la première vidéo
il n'y a pas de durée particulière ne
fait pas non plus de 30 minutes mais il
fait ce que vous voulez à votre manière
comme vous souhaitez la deuxième c'est
un format un peu plus court 30 secondes
une minute saint-yzan youtube c'est un
peu cette idée là je n'en ai rempli de
partager la vidéo que vous avez créés
dont vous êtes le plus fier c'est que
vous pourriez montrer à n'importe quel
nous on regarde ça c'est mon taf
c'est ce que je fais j'en suis hyper
fier regarde ça en gros c'est votre
carte de visite vidéo
envoyez moi ça que je regarde vraiment
ce qu'il en est on se quitte toute une
série de questions à vous poser
dans l'idéal
vous voulez répondre en vidéo c'est pas
plus mal sauf si vous n'êtes pas à
l'aise dans l'idée d'être filmés devant
une caméra je vous dis pas plus à
l'appel diffusé c'est que pour moi c'est
que pour l'instant il poursuit c'est le
regarder si ça vous dérange de le faire
en vidéo pouvez-vous répondre par mail
m'envoyait un petit dock ce que voulait
ça ça fonctionne absolument aucun
problème alors les questions sont les
suivantes alors bien évidemment nom
prénom âge ce que vous faites si ça n'a
rien gagné on en passe et des meilleures
quelles sont vos références sur youtube
est ce que vous regardez youtube et si
oui quelles sont vos références quels
sont les chaînes que vous aimez regarder
tes coupe attaquer on s'en fout ça
vraiment c'est pas du tout important
quelles sont vos références globale en
termes de production de vidéos
que ce soit dans le cinéma ailleurs à
droite à gauche que vous voulez quelles
sont vos références ou non mais t'es pas
plus de 3 4 les plus forts pour je
puisse vraiment vous captez vous
remettez des tonnes soit un petit peu
plus compliqué quels sont pour vous on
se bat cette fois ci sur la chaîne i les
points d'amélioration sur ma chaîne
qu'est ce qui ne va pas au terme de
format vidéo qu'est ce qui pourrait être
amélioré
qu'est ce que vous vous pourriez
apporter et qu'est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut mettre en place rapidement
dans un premier temps pour effectivement
amélioré le format en gros quel regard
vous portez vous sur ma chaîne de façon
critique pour permettre effectivement de
faire avancer un peu l'histoire et de ce
fait pourquoi est ce que vous vous
devriez avoir le poste pourquoi est-ce
que vous êtes la bonne personne pour me
rejoindre l'équipe parce que vous allez
pouvoir apporter vraiment votre pâte
apporter quelque chose au rang d'un côté
un peu plus technique sur quoi est ce
que vous travaillez mac pc
quels sont les logiciels que vous
utilisez logiciel de montage de
compression ici et ça a été tu as là
j'en passe et des meilleurs quel est
votre process de montage comment est-ce
que vous travaillez ce que vous avez un
process défini lorsque vous travaillez
du décrochage remonte à gc ca est ce que
ça vous fait pas peur de faire plus
d'une vidéo par jour
est ce que vous savez faire des
miniatures est ce que vous pourriez en
faire si vous en avez déjà fait envoyer
mme hazan quelques-unes une fois de plus
celle dont vous êtes et plus fier pour
spis voir votre travail
c'est un poste de monteur mais
potentiellement de temps en temps très
exceptionnellement vous pourriez faire
un petit peu de tournage est ce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser
oui ou non c'est un poste de monteur a
donc si vous dites non ça ne choque
absolument pas que ça posera pas de
problème soissons pour le recrutement
dès lors vous à quelque chose de
particulier on parle de teck sur la
chaîne alors qu'ils n'ont pas forcément
d'être un passionné de teck ou des mails
attaque mais quel est votre rapport à la
tech est ce que vous aimez la
technologie est ce qu'elle vous
intéresse est ce que ça vous intéresse
de monter des vidéos qui parle de take
on va parler de tel qu'un la chaîne
parle de teck donc on va en parler de
différentes manières mais on en parlera
toujours le fil conducteur est
vous intéresse est ce qu a contrario au
latex et pas trop votre truc est ce que
vous êtes plus porté sur le sierra et
est ce que le fait de bosser dans la
tête ça pourrait vous intéresser
soyez vraiment très très transparent il
tarn est ainsi la technique moi ça
m'intéresse pas trop mais le fait
d'avoir un tremplin pour monter des
vidéos sur paris sur youtube ça
m'intéresse je peux entendre que le
comprendra soyez vraiment hypra hypra
transparent on n'est pas là pour se
raconter des balivernes faut se dire la
vérité
droit dans les yeux droit dans
l'objectif une question est ce que vous
seriez prêt à voyager
s'il y avait des besoins daria qui se
créent peut-être pour des extras de
tournage de montage ou des conditions un
peu particulières et quel salaire vous
souhaiteriez avoir pour ce poste je vous
demande également de m'envoyer un
curriculum vitae fameux cv pour voir un
petit peu votre parcours vous inquiétez
pas je suis pas extrêmement fort mal là
dessus mais c'est quand même pour avoir
un peu de visibilité sur d'où venait ce
que vous avez fait qu'est ce que vous
avez fait dans la vie je ne me formalise
pas si vous n'avez pas travaillé pendant
des années dans ce métier là c'est pas
grave je pouvais débutant dès lors vous
avez une vision une façon de faire une
perspective ça c'est vraiment un prix
intéressant c'est vraiment quelque chose
que je veux venir chercher c'est une
particularité quelque chose de très
différent sion je sais ce que j'aime
youtube je sais ce que j'aime absolument
pas je sais les formats que j'aime je
sais vraiment ce que je déteste je vais
pas vous le dire vraiment noir que vous
avez à me proposer pas non plus vous
donner toutes les cartes tout de suite
je vous dis donc c'est un poste à temps
plein qui est basé à paris vous à dire
travailler dans mon studio à paris
jouffre une jolie petite place on aura l
tout le matos pour bosser ensemble sera
vachement bien je vous demande donc de
m'envoyer ça toutes vos vidéos vous les
envoyer par lui transfère ce que vous
voulez de dropbox et compagnie vous
m'envoyez a job
@ monsieur gros point fr vous avez
jusqu'au 6 mars prochain pour m'envoyer
toutes vos candidatures le 6 mars au
soir je clos les candidatures je regarde
tout ça j'aurais déjà regardé au fur et
à mesure indique ça arrive je regarde je
me mets les notations je mets ça de côté
et si vous êtes retenu je vous
recontacterai et puis on se verra où on
en discutera ça c'est la première étape
pour permettre effectivement biens de
voir les personnes qui sont intéressées
et tout ce que j'ai et ensuite je veux
vraiment sélectionnés et apprendre
rencontrera directement pour pouvoir en
parler et voir un peu ce qu'on peut
faire ensemble si ça vous intéresse je
vous laisse le temps de faire vos
projets de monter tout ça de me faire
les plus belles vidéos lévy dont vous
êtes le plus fier je vous dis une fois
de plus vous dites pas qu'il vous faut
quinze jours trois semaines pour faire
la vidéo ou même grosse journée des
nuits entières puisque lorsqu'on va
travailler ensemble il va falloir
comment sortir quelques unes plus d'une
vidéo par jour donc il faut être capable
de monter rapidement efficacement et en
ayant vraiment un truc hyper impactant
derrière
on voit tout ça et puis n'hésitez pas à
faire passer le message si ça vous
intéresse pas forcément aussi vous voyez
des années qui pourrait intéresser
partagés sur tous les réseaux comme ça
ça permettra effectivement de diffuser
au maximum sa formation
ça peut être vraiment cool voilà sur ce
je suis super content parce que voyez il
se passe des choses parce que les choses
évoluent du jour où j'ai commencé à
créer une chaîne youtube j'aurais jamais
imaginé faire cette vidéo les enquêtes
jure kruth un monteur là aujourd'hui je
parle de poste de monteur j'ose imaginer
espérer que dans les temps à venir gare
en plein d'autres opportunités qui se
créent et pour savoir tout ça vous avez
évidemment à vous abonner à me rejoindre
et à mon avis on va manger plein gbagbo
sera contre nous embrasser des bisous et
à demain
[Musique]